[Music]
after one minute and 12 seconds of logos
another 12 seconds of credits are
dedicated to those same studios is this
movie saying that the world is so
obsessed with Wendy Williams and the
Real Housewives of Miami that we didn't
pay attention to the environmental
warning signs kids jump on sleep and
parents beds so we know this is a loving
family cliche this truck literally comes
out of nowhere
it's know we're behind the cop when he
drives up to Jerry and it makes no sound
before it smashes into it shaky cam is
shaky zombies are fast cliche wait
somehow during all this commotion trying
to get his daughters to safety Jerry
focuses on one random zombie act in the
middle of the whole city of mayhem how
in the fuck does this RV not get taken
by oh the other thousand people running
around the street it's a wonder that the
previous owners abandoned this RV
considering there are absolutely no cars
in front of it while Jerry drives it
discount inception music movie rips off
the kid has asthma to add dramatic
tension thing from science and goomy's
and why do vehicles always have trouble
starting during zombie apocalypses movie
simulates post-apocalyptic Newark with
stock footage of regular Newark I don't
even know too many grocery stores that
have motor oil for sale much less
located near the dairy section but
anything that's convenient for our hero
to lean up against during a gunfight I
guess that's what she said
and that's what I said water all over
not just like a bureaucrat to need to
organize the delivery of drinking water
to for people but Welsh at the feet of
the world is in the hands of the guy
that caused the Skynet Judgment Day
event then we're all fucked and she
loves disguising her weaknesses as
strengths its weaknesses that it doesn't
like sick people how is that a weakness
disguised as a strength again one of the
first main characters to die during the
zombie outbreak movie dies by slipping
on metal it's a zombie movie guys if you
want to take out the doctor guy and
leave Brad Pitt on his own to deal with
the mission that's okay I'm cool with
that
just maybe haven't get taken out by a
zombie like this other soldier here does
instead of something absolutely stupid
tooth pulling fucking sprint even though
three of those turn off your cell phone
commercials played before this movie
asshole Jerry still leaves his on during
this sound sensitive trick to the plane
I began my investigation on the
assumption and when they said zombies it
meant zombies there is no way that an
outbreak that turns people into zombies
would go unnoticed in this day and age
and this movie is clearly set in the
time of Twitter and reddit where you can
read about things in real time so the
fact that Israel was the only country to
figure out what was going on is
completely ludicrous but okay let's
assume every country in the world is
stupid if Israel was indeed the only
country to figure this out then how did
they build a zombie wall in time around
a city that is a hundred and twenty-five
square kilometers and why didn't they
share information with everyone else why
didn't they send video and photos to the
world like to the Internet and say hey
look there's fucking zombies everywhere
you might want to do something about
this just to balance two out and during
all this dudes research about zombies he
didn't find out that they get crazy when
they hear lots of noise and that maybe
it would be wise to keep the sound down
to a minute
so wait behind this wall there's always
a bunch of commotion buses driving in
helicopters flying overhead but it's the
singing that makes the zombies warm the
zombie pyramid to scale the wall what is
this the walking dead hero who also with
all these helicopters flying around how
did they miss this how did the zombie
get on this plane he's clearly not shown
catching up to the plane on the runway
so he must have gotten in here before
and was he hiding
does zombies hide and if this dumbwaiter
a compartment thing is important enough
to exist on the plane then why didn't
anyone to open it before now right at
the end of the flight was it just so the
plane crash could still happen close
enough to Jerry's destination that he
could get there before nightfall
Jerry just watched these things scale a
gigantic wall and yet he still wastes
precious time and effort building a
suitcase fort to try and keep them out
know what this place is of course I do
it's why I'm here then you understand
how this must look to us huh this guy
has been lying unconscious for three
days never once showed a hint of
becoming a zombie and you're scared of
what he might do for what reason again
back on the plane we were told this
phone's battery ran out
did the w-h-o facility just happen to
have a charger for this particular phone
lying around also they've had this
mystery person lying unconscious for
three days and they never bothered to
call anyone on the phone to figure out
who he was I'm sorry I know this is
tough news but is it so hard to complete
this sentence can't you just say that
you had to kick his family off the boat
like a bunch of dogs instead of leaving
him hanging I understand I do yeah yes
yes family no and you couldn't possibly
understand could you I know how you feel
you can't possibly know um I feel cliche
brother I lost my son - so Jerry asks
this dude he has a family and he says no
like he's never had one leading to the
righteous anger and then nope I really
did have a family asshole and they're
dead now don't you feel like a total
cock right about now I'm sorry you have
nothing to be sorry for Jerry we all
heard that dude mislead you into the you
can't possibly know how I feel cliche
that's the boss
9 6 4 so wait a minute they didn't
bother to give everyone the code just in
case this very thing happened and when
Jerry goes into the room he has no idea
what he's looking for
and somehow they went on this mission
without Jerry suddenly working phone or
a walkie-talkie which they clearly have
but hey I guess anything to make the
mission harder so it's more dramatic for
the audience right but ok let's assume
that everyone is dumb and/or there are
no communication devices whatsoever
there isn't an intercom in this place
just in case there's an emergency or
something it seems like once they found
out that zombies were attracted to the
noise they could have just dropped
stereos blaring Creed into stadiums like
this all around the world and just blow
them up if he uses anything he took from
that left case he's dead anyway he was a
zombie
[Music]
Worcestershire sauce emergency line this
call might be monitored to ensure you
the highest quality service how may I
help you
there's a bunch of zombie here please
hold guns are half-measures how they
[Music]
what is this what happened to had you
slip you didn't sleep on his steed